c'était le 31 juillet 2003 à vilnius en
lituanie
bertrand cantat la tête dans ses mains
kc touche le fond l'actrice marie
trintignant sa maîtresse est sur le
point de mourir après qu'il l'ait battu
au cours d'une dispute passionnel alors
que le chanteur de noir désir
seul désespéré voix s'abattre sur lui
une tornade médiatique
[Musique]
une femme va lui tendre la main
son épouse kristina rady qui accourent
pour le soutenir
la première fois qu'elle le voit après
le drame elle est la seule présente
geste tendre elle a le visage bouleversé
mais on voit que sa main voilà elle a eu
lui caresse la tête pour dire je suis là
tout va bien
bordeaux
dimanche 10 janvier 2010
et
dans cette maison kristina rady se
suicide par pendaison
alors que bertrand cantat dort à l'étagé
du dessous dans le quartier cette mère
de deux jeunes enfants était bien connue
du voisinage
elle semblait heureuse et personne ne
comprend son geste
[Musique]
ces gamins se balader mais ces gamins
étaient en vélo toujours souriant
toujours bon jovi aucun problème et rien
ne laissait à croire qu'elle avait des
problèmes
j'arrivais le matin le soir je suis
quelqu'un de charmant avec ce qu'elle
avait vécu avec ce qu'elle avait
surmonté avec je pense je pensais que
elle sortait la tête de l'eau
voyez je pensais plutôt que c'était la
phase d'amélioration de service
là je trouve ça vraiment on a été très
traumatisée
pourquoi kristina rady s'est elle donné
la mort alors que son grand combat pour
le père de ses enfants était derrière
elle
qui était vraiment cette jeune femme
courageuse soutien indéfectible d'un
homme qui pourtant l'avait quittée
[Musique]
l'histoire commence dans le bruit et la
fureur d'un grand festival de musique à
budapest
nous sommes en 1993 et kristina rady
travail
c'est une jeune hongroise de 25 ans et
une brillante traductrice qui parle
quatre langues dont le français
c'est aussi une fêtarde au tempérament
d'artiste andrade ardak directeur de
l'institut culturel hongrois paris est
un ami de jeunesse était très libre
le mot pain que ça ne sommes pas le plus
12 exact mais dans le bon sens du sterne
elle était jamais rieuse s'intéresser
tout très très énergiques
bertrand cantat et son groupe noir désir
viennent jouer dans le festival de
budapest
il tombe amoureux en 97
le couple s'installe à bordeaux la ville
de bertrand cantat et se marie à
première enfant né mais kristina rady ne
se transforme pas en femme au foyer
groupe i de son mari bien que loin de
son pays elle est active de son côté et
mène à bien de nombreux projets comme la
traduction de ce recueil d'un poète
hongrois attila joseph sévères sont un
peu comme les chansons de bertrand des
textes très très très fort passé
beaucoup de temps à traduire en fait
tout ce travail qu'en deux ans je crois
les textes ont même donné lieu à un
spectacle qui à la mise en scène
en 2002 elle est enceinte d'un deuxième
enfant de bertrand cantat mais c'est à
ce moment là que son couple bascule le 3
juillet au cours d'un concert à
vaison-la-romaine bertrand cantat fait
cette fois ci la rencontre de la
comédienne marie trintignant le début
d'une folle passion amoureuse mais une
passion qui va se révéler destructrice
l'été suivant le chanteur suit sa
nouvelle compagne sur un tournage à
vilnius en lituanie
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 juillet 2003 au
cours d'une très violente dispute
il lui donne des coups qui lui seront
mortels déboussolés par cet acte fou
seul entre ses gardiens qui tente de
mettre fin à ses jours et de manière
étonnante
christina la femme délaissée qui vient
d'accoucher de leur deuxième enfant une
petite fille vole donc à son secours
ce n'est pas venu naturellement c'est
une à cause d'un coach et qui m'a donné
après après la tragédie et à cause du
fait que ce coup de filet a été très
alarmant pour moi et aussi parce que
merdre a perdu connaissance pendant le
coup de filet et je devais être à cet
endroit pour essayer de comprendre pour
essayer de de dd
un an plus tard en mars 2004
nous dépendons justice et paix
malheureuse mais bien présente au procès
où elle va veiller de nouveau sur
bertrand cantat et les dés de manière
décisive alors que la mère de marie
trintignant
derrière laquelle toute la famille fait
bloc et défendu par un ténor du barreau
georges kiejman sur le banc d'à côté
christina rassemble et mobilise le clan
cantat
quant à elle a dans le box la soeur et
ses parents de son père sa mère auprès
non désir denis saint paul elle a
organisé les différentes venues des uns
et des autres c'est elle qui s'est battu
pour que tout le clan soit là que
l'argent soit là qu'ils puissent louer
un appartement qu'ils puissent payer des
avions puissent venir
et puis surtout à la barre devant les
juges elle remet en cause le portrait
d'homme violent qui est fait de son mari
bertrand est un homme très honnête qui
dans les situations extrêmes privilégie
toujours le dialogue et la parole je
n'aurais jamais pu vivre partager 10 ans
de ma vie avec un menteur un macho et un
castagneur c'est un radis a été la
meilleure avocate de bertrand cantat
c'est à dire selon vous il aurait pris
plus célèbre était là on ne peut jamais
savoir n'est elle a eu un effet
extrêmement positif et même notre kezman
était troublé par son témoignage et à la
fin il eu pour seule réponse de dire
bertrand cantat quelle chance vous avez
d'avoir une femme pareille elle le
défend de toutes ses forces
alors qu'il l'avait quittée pour marie
trintignant
c'est le père de ses enfants elle fait
ça pour ses enfants à la base c'est les
enfants alice est la leur fille leur
fils à cinq ans leur fille a même pas un
nom ou à tout juste un an
donc elle elle s'occupe de lui pour ses
enfants parce qu'il veut voilà elle veut
que les enfants aient une vie à peu près
normale malgré le drame
bertrand cantat est condamné à sept ans
de prison
l'accusation réclamé 8 quelques mois
plus tard il est transféré dans cette
prison française près de toulouse
la fidl christina ici avec le deuxième
enfant du couple vient le voir et
continue de veiller sur lui qu'ils
puissent se reconstruire
le 15 octobre 2007 après quatre ans et
trois mois de détention il bénéficie
d'une libération conditionnelle
progressivement à bordeaux bertrand
cantat et kristina rady reprennent une
vie de famille
le couple s'était reformé cela faisait
un an que il avait repris la vie commune
dans l'intérêt des enfants
il y avait plus de difficultés entre eux
le dimanche 10 janvier 2010 dans leur
maison du quartier nansouty
à la mi journée le fils aîné du couple
découvre christina pendu à laitages
bertrand cantat d'or au rez de chaussée
la jeune femme de 41 ans s'est suicidé
pour la justice cette hypothèse ne fait
pas de doutes allaient conforter cette
hypothèse bien évidemment on par les
constatations médicales ça c'est
extrêmement important faites sur place
mais qui vont être confirmée également
par autopsie par l'autopsié réalisée
lundi dernier qui exclut totalement
toute intervention de tiers on n'a donc
pas du tout de traces de coups pas du
tout de trace de lui qu'il ya eu des
écrits laissés par maladie qui confirme
voilà qu on est bien qu'elle cette
personne a décidé de se suicider la
présence de bertrand cantat n'est pas un
élément j'allais dire fondamental de
cette affaire nous sommes sur une
affaire de suicide avec des informations
dont nous avons effectivement une
connaissance qui sont des informations
qui relèvent de la vie privée
exclusivement la vie privée de cette
femme et qui doit être respectée même si
elle a décidé de mettre fin à ses jours
elle a justifié son geste par écrit
auprès de sa famille
pourquoi cette femme qui aimait tant ses
enfants et qui avait fait le plus dur
avec bertrand cantat a mis fin à ses
jours
même pour ses amis cela reste un mystère
je vais pas expliquer à expliquer c'est
quelque chose complètement inattendu
elle était très très forte c'était une
des plus fortes femmes que je connais à
qui était toujours optimiste qui hammam
qui est toujours cherché la solution pas
les problèmes
j'ai beaucoup d'amis au téléphone et on
essaye à analyser pourquoi comment caen
qu'est ce qui se passait et personne ne
s'est pas expliqué sept ans après la
disparition de marie trintignant
bertrand cantat fait donc face à un
deuxième drame
cette fois ci il n'aura plus son ange
gardien pour le réconforter
[Musique]
monde